plus de caméras aux abords des collèges
du Loir-et-Cher un dispositif pourrait
voir le jour prochainement une
convention relative au renforcement de
la vidéoprotection à proximité de ces
établissements vient d'être signés par
l'État le département et les
associations des maires du Loir-et-Cher
un million 300000 euros vont être
débloqués pour permettre au 21 communes
accueillant ses collèges de mettre en
place ce dispositif sur la base du
volontariat reportage de Sarago
un coup de stylo pour un coup de pouce
financier désormais les communes peuvent
demander des subventions publiques pour
installer des caméras de vidéos
protection aux abords des collèges les
dispositifs ont une vocation dissuasive
ce sera des caméras qui seront visibles
qui ont pour vocation première de
dissuader les actes de délinquance aux
abords des collèges 21 communes peuvent
désormais installer ce dispositif pour
26 collèges en Loir-et-Cher 6 sont déjà
concernés le budget est plafonné à 50000
euros pour 6 camera maximum le Conseil
départemental et l'Etat apporte une
subvention à hauteur de 40% chacun reste
à charge 20% pour la commune ces caméras
seront disposées sur la voie publique
entre les zones de parking et l'entrée
des établissements les images transmises
directement jusqu'à la gendarmerie un
système qui apporte des avantages pour
les forces de l'ordre ça porte une
grosse plus-value en termes de
résolution d'enquête d'éléments de
preuve d'identification des auteurs on
[Musique]
déjà déployées sur le département